we start with breaking news one person
in custody right now after an incident
at Shadow Ridge High School a report of
a gun near campus that campus is now on
lockdown this is a moving situation
Joshua peguero is live at the scene with
the latest Joshua
hello John sources are telling eight
news now that there was a report of a
student with a gun nearby Shadow Ridge
and now a Metro Police say that they
have one person detained I'm gonna step
out of the way here so you can get a
look and our viewers can get a look at
the at the scene Clark County School
police are also assisting Metro in this
matter there have been no injuries
reported let me make that clear no
injuries reported Metro is in the school
with ccsdpd students tell eight news now
police were going through each classroom
and are searching students as well we
even saw a picture of a kid sitting down
a room as police walk through the school
with large guns again no injuries have
been reported and we haven't heard of an
arrest just someone is detained but we
don't know if that the person that's
detained is a student now back out here
live I've also learned Metro is doing a
safety screening and will then do a
controlled staggered release of students
now the reunificationary told from
police is going to happen at that shirts
LDS there are also several parents out
here that want answers from police and
police are assuring them that they'll
make sure they give it to them once
they're done with this second clearing
reporting live near Shadow Ridge High
School Joshua progero 8 news now all
right Joshua thank you very much we'll
certainly keep an eye on what's going on
up there all throughout the rest of the
afternoon